so i've just watched the end of the
orville
is that the most important sci-fi series
on television right now
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
first of all i'm just going to very
quickly apologize for doing the video
like this i didn't get my green screen
and everything but this
episode and this seriously orville i've
just watched the last one and the future
unknown episode and i've just got to say
i was absolutely blown away by it
the
whole series has been phenomenal the the
main thing i really like is that disney
has really stepped up with this episode
and actually given them enough money to
produce a tv show
that lived up to what it deserved for me
the first two series were great but the
special effects were never really good
enough um i was thinking about the one
episode where they ended up traveling
through a two-dimensional space
looked awful it looked from like the
1980s or something it was really really
bad the last star fighter's special
effects were much much better
um but in this series new horizons and
that's why they went with calling it the
orville new horizons because they most
definitely wanted to separate a little
bit from the first two seasons and show
that they were doing something new with
it
um really really stepped up the special
effects at times were excellent i think
it was on par with anything star trek is
doing right now
we'll come back to star trek in a second
um and as a whole the show was produced
and designed beautifully
star trek though has
the orville just become another star
trek series well at the moment that
wouldn't necessarily be a bad thing
because star trek is particularly
strange new world is doing very very
well at the moment it's back to its best
i think with strange new worlds
the oilville always felt like a homage
to the next generation for me in
particular and other people have called
it a parody because of the
um humor that really bled through with
the first two seasons
the humor that on the whole has been
lacking from new horizons so could you
argue she's become another star trek
series
well i don't actually think that's fair
because there is still humor and
particularly in the last episode i think
there's real grown up
rather than silly fart jokes which maybe
we got a lot in the first two series
it's actually matured into a proper tv
show with grown up humor laugh out loud
humor in lots and bits in the last
episode i don't want to do too many
spoilers but
the kailan turning up to the wedding for
example spoiler oh there was a wedding
um
it's just very very funny the way that
isaac
has that conversation with the prime the
way he says well should we all come and
i should just say yes that would be
lovely and then four thousand kalon
warships turn up it's ju it's it's
generally left out loud funny bortis is
very funny in this episode as well with
all the humor with the best man's speech
and things
i could have done without the song at
the end i won't lie but again
we won't go into too much today i don't
want to spoil the episode if you haven't
quite caught it yet
i genuinely think though this this tv
show has matured and has become a
grown-up show a grown-up sci-fi show but
it still keeps the element of the humor
this show is very much seth macfarlane's
baby
we're going to talk about woke because
that's what a lot of people say about
this show that it is a woke show that
it's it's very much about agenda before
story i completely disagree with that
and i completely tell you not to like to
to be honest if you think this show's
woke you never watch star trek ever
because lots of star trek and things
will always work they always talk about
racism and things like this
i actually think seth macfarlane does
put the story first always has done and
he is a massive sci-fi fan and it just
shows his geek don't really just come
out in this series but also he is
he isn't a conservative let's be honest
he is probably a democrat he is quite
liberal in his views that does shine
through in the show but he also does it
quite thoughtful ways a lot of the
things within the story like when we
talked about suicide stuff in very
earlier episodes
he he did actually try to write in
both sides of certain arguments and
create you know a thoughtful episode
rather than just telling you what's
right and wrong
he showed all elements of that
conversation he then went with what he
believes and he and that projected
through the show
um but this isn't an agenda of disney or
anybody else this is the writers
opinions coming through as all good
sci-fi should be i would say that the
orville is woke
but in the right way like all sci-fi is
orville is awake
it discusses
several very uncomfortable
um things in our society
and it does again in this episode i
think this episode should have been
called the prime directive myself um i
do love how in the orville in this
particular episode and there is the
whole thing with prime directive that
they don't interfere with society but
they actually gave us a bit of depth in
this episode on why that is um rather
than just a star trek way of doing which
is well that's just the prime directive
that's just what we do and they they
talk about it every so often maybe we
actually have a specific reason why the
union has this
policy this law this how we do not act
like god in that galaxy but anyway
getting back to the woke thing
there are elements with this story that
are uncomfortable
there are
issues that are raised in this series
that are at times uncomfortable to watch
but it's done through
a medium of sci-fi which is perfect to
ask those questions you can come away
with it completely disagreeing with
second father and completely hate in the
show if you insist
but
i personally think this is a really
important way and unique within most of
different ways of media that you can
tell these stories and you can have
these discussions and raise these issues
with metaphors and with you know alien
races that you can't do in other media
on the subject of woke as well i'm going
to talk about the character and i've
written a name next i can never remember
it uh ensenburg who has been accused of
being the typical mary sue
she came into the series
she had
a very disturbing background that was
she was a lesbian and her even though
that was never specifically said i don't
think it was very heavily implied i
think we got to the point where it was
more than just implied to be fair but
she was a lesbian and her partner her
the love of her life dies during the
kaelin attack she hated isaac
and people have said that the shooting
basically came on she's a genius she's a
genius like this fourth dimensional
thing and she couldn't do any wrong
she's the typical mary sue but then she
sacrifices herself at the end of episode
nine spoilers again sorry
um and it then comes through that they
have that full circle of her character
that she puts her hatred to one side
and she does the right thing even though
that means the kalon who she wants to
wipe out would survive within the galaxy
but it gives a hope for the galaxy for
actual peace
the whole point of her character was for
that story arc
um yes okay she might have been a bit of
a mary sue
i don't really like that term but um she
might have been that but it was for a
reason and again that is something that
seth mcfarlane does repeatedly in the
series and why this series isn't woke
and i don't care what you say isn't
but the main thing i'm going to say
about the author and why i think it
might genuinely be one of the most
important tv shows on tv right now
is that
it does it in a way
that is
just thoughtful
with a sense of humor a grown-up sense
of humour now
and even though a series four of the
oval is not confirmed yet the seth
macfarlane still says look it's it's
what disney decide i'm hoping we get a
new horizons series 2 or an oval series
4 really really soon
it's genuinely a grown-up sci-fi show
for grown-ups
and
it might be my favorite sci-fi show on
tv right now
and that's saying quite a lot because
strange new worlds was bloody good
so tell me what you think get in the
comments what did you think of series
three of orville new horizons
and you know is this show woke or is it
actually woke in a good way
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
it really helps us out also if you enjoy
the content please consider becoming a
fully fledged site tracker and hit that
joining button
as always guys i'll see you next time
stay safe
[Music]
you